okay so the topic of this video is
cellular respiration let's go ahead and
get started so right here this molecule
adenosine triphosphate this is why the
cell performs cellular respiration it's
trying to make this because ATP is the
energy molecule used by the cell you'll
often hear ATP as an analogy compared to
money or the currency of a cell because
you know we spend money on goods and
services and the cell will spend ATP to
perform you know these these reactions
and many others that I did not list but
here's the triphosphate part notice how
there are three phosphates and they're
in the bonds of these three phosphates
particularly between the second and
third phosphate is energy and in the
hydrolysis of ATP if you've forgotten
that hydro means water and lysis means
to break down so in the breakdown of ATP
ATP with water will yield adp a single
phosphate and energy and it's this
energy that will power the cell and so
in this very simplified diagram of an
ATP molecule here comes water and my
scissors represent the actions of an
enzyme and that third phosphate tends to
be broken off and in that energy is
released and it's this energy that will
often drive the cellular processes that
you see listed in the notes so how is
this molecule of ATP created well ATP
gets created through cellular
respiration cells need ATP to power
their chemical reactions and most ATP
gets produced by the powerhouse of the
cell the mitochondria the powerhouse
because it produces the ATP power now
ATP is created through this process of
cellular respiration which we're going
to go through in the rest of this video
and what happens is a molecule of
glucose that we get from our food is
gonna be broken down to make a whole
bunch of molecules of ATP
that's what half
during the the process of cellular
respiration glycolysis the Krebs cycle
the electron transport chain these are
all breaking down molecules of glucose
from our food to produce ATP so let's
move into glycolysis okay starting with
glycolysis the location takes place in
the cytoplasm of a cell and what happens
is that blue hexagon ring labeled
glucose glucose is going to be broken
down by molecules of ATP a molecule
called nad in various enzymes now for
simplicity I've only drawn the six
carbons of glucose in my diagram but
glucose you can see also has 12
hydrogen's and six oxygens so what
happens is two molecules of ATP plus and
plus enzymes are going to begin to break
down glucose then this might seem a
little counterproductive using ATP to
make ATP but keep in mind the goal is to
make a lot of ATP so if you have to
spend a little bit of ATP to make a lot
of ATP it's worth it
so a molecule of ATP plus the scissors
representing an enzyme will begin to
break down glucose into this
intermediate molecule here so next
another molecule of ATP and a different
enzyme will be broken down and the
energy from ATP will break that
intermediate down into two molecules
labeled P gal or phosphoglyceraldehyde
now P gal itself this is another
intermediate it will be broken down
further in a moment
so next enzymes which are in the
cytoplasm will add another phosphate
unto each of the P gals so here's an
enzyme the scissors adding a phosphate
to the P gal on the left and and the
phosphate being added to the P gal on
the right and by doing this this
converts the P gal into another
intermediate molecule
so next couple molecules called NADH are
going to be created and will enter the
mitochondria well they begin as
molecules call of nad and nad is in
abbreviation for nicotinamide adenine
dinucleotide and what happens of course
there's enzymes involved nad with the
help of an enzyme will strip off the
hydrogen to create NADH NADH can be
looked at as a hydrogen carrier carries
the hydrogen over to the mitochondria
the same thing happens with the other
nad an enzyme will help to strip off a
hydrogen and NADH will carry that
hydrogen over to the mitochondria these
are going to be very very important when
we get to the electron transport chain
so now that we're near the end of
glycolysis let's talk about how four
molecules of ATP are created
you see those four yellow circles with
the P those each represent a phosphate
group and what happens is here is four
molecules of ATP and ADP along with the
help of an enzyme will strip off one of
those phosphates to create a molecule of
ATP now this happens three more times an
ADP with the help of an enzyme will
strip off one of those phosphates to
make ATP adp strips off a phosphate to
make ATP and ADP again strips off a
phosphate with the help of enzymes to
make ATP and what we're left with what
was once glucose is now these two
molecules called pyruvates and the
pyruvates are gonna be very useful in
the Krebs cycle coming up we also have a
total amount of four ATP molecules
created although sometimes you'll hear
it referred to as a net gain of two
ATP's well what do we mean by that well
four ATP's are created but two ATP's
were used to start the process of
glycolysis so when you subtract the two
at the start from the four that were
created that's what we made net gain
well what happens next
what happens next depends upon the type
of cell and the conditions that the cell
is within there's two possible pathways
and both of them are going to involve
those pyruvates those pyruvates are
going to be broken down even further the
pathway that we're gonna follow in these
notes is the aerobic pathway with oxygen
leading to the Krebs cycle and the
electron transport chain
but if oxygen is lacking if a cell is in
an anaerobic environment those pyruvates
will be used in fermentation I have a
different video if you want to learn
about fermentation but this video is
gonna follow the aerobic pathway so here
we are back at our cell glycolysis has
just completed itself and we're about to
start the krebs cycle and so the two
molecules of pyruvate will migrate into
the mitochondria so let's go into the
mitochondria and take a closer look and
when we zoom into the mitochondria so
there's the two pyruvates notice how
they're in the mitochondrial matrix the
inner inner fluid layer of the
mitochondria and so what happens is
we're gonna follow the pyruvate on the
left now the same thing happens the
pyruvate on the right but for simplicity
we're gonna just follow the one on the
left the peruvians gonna be broken down
into acetic acid in the process of doing
this NADH is gonna be created so there's
a molecule of nad when pyruvate is being
broken down nad will come and strip off
a hydrogen to make NADH notice Haussmann
carbon dioxide was created as well
that's just waste what we're left with
is acetic acid acetic acid being a
intermediate molecule what happens next
is a really large molecule that I'm
being very simplistic in just drawing it
and labeling it Co a coenzyme a really
large molecule will bond to acetic acid
well how big is coenzyme a we'll look at
the formula of acetic acid when we bond
coenzyme a we form acetyl co a look at
how large that formula is
so acetyl co a is also an intermediate
molecule it's just the next step of the
krebs cycle what happens to the acetyl
co a the third step and this is where
this the krebs cycle also gets its name
of the citric acid cycle acetyl co a is
going to be converted and broken down
into citric acid that happens when a
four carbon molecule from the previous
krebs cycle bonds to the acetyl co a and
i have it flashing for a reason I hope
you all understand why it's flashing
when we get to the end I wanted to do
something for you to member out to
remember this four carbon molecule from
the previous krebs cycle so an enzyme
will bond that four carbon molecule to
the acetyl co a and the coenzyme a
breaks away and what you're left with is
citric acid citric acid being a six
carbon molecule okay so the six carbon
citric acid will be broken down into a
five carbon molecule and in the process
of doing this NADH is created so here's
a molecule of nad nad along with an
enzyme will help to break down the
citric acid notice how NADH was created
also some carbon dioxide waste was
generated this is why citric acid went
from a six carbon to a five carbon
molecule so what about this five carbon
molecule this five carbon molecule is
again an intermediate it's gonna be
broken down into a four carbon molecule
and in the break down a couple things
happen
number one another molecule of NADH is
created so there's nad with the help of
an enzyme nad will strip off a hydrogen
but that's not the only thing that
happens a molecule of ATP will be
created because in the matrix of the
mitochondria there are various solutes
and molecules dissolved within the
matrix and here's a molecule of adp and
a phosphate and
bring these molecules together and in
the breakdown of this five carbon
molecule into a four carbon molecule the
ATP is bonded together and also in the
act of doing this carbon dioxide waste
is created so that's how it goes from a
five carbon to a four carbon molecule
now this four carbon molecule is again
an intermediate enzymes will rearrange
the four carbon molecule into another
four carbon molecule and in the process
of doing this a molecule of NADH is
created that means we have to have nad
come along and strip off a hydrogen and
then another molecule very similar to
nad called
F ad is gonna come on in and strip off
not one but two hydrogen's forming fadh2
now all of these NADH is in this fadh2
they have a role to play we just haven't
seen it yet their role is coming up in a
few moments well what happens with this
four carbon molecule that's just been
rearranged notice how it's flashing now
that's because this is the same flashing
four carbon molecule we saw earlier
remember the Krebs cycle is a cycle so I
wanted to do something for you to
realize when the krebs cycle was
beginning its next turn and what happens
with this four carbon molecule it will
bond with acetyl co a that really big
molecule we saw earlier so enzymes will
bind it together the coenzyme a breaks
away and what we're left with is the six
carbon molecule known as citric acid and
the process repeats itself well when we
look at what's created an overview of
the Krebs cycle this always frustrated
me because I always thought that you
know cellular respiration is purpose is
to make a lot of ATP and only two
molecules of ATP were created one
molecule of ATP from the pyruvate on the
left one molecule of ATP from the
pyruvate on the right but the big prize
of the krebs cycle is not the two
molecules of ATP it's all the nad
and fadh2 that was created those are
really important in the electron
transport chain so let's look at that
next so as we move on into the electron
transport chain what we're gonna do is
we're gonna zoom in to the membrane of
the matrix and when we zoom on in here
here we are so now that we've zoomed in
we can see embedded in the inner
mitochondrial membrane are some great
herbs and cylinders these are symbolic
of the protein complexes that are
embedded inside this membrane here and
these are gonna help to kind of drive
the electron transport chain
now we're gonna see why all the nadh and
fadh2 is created well here's a molecule
of NADH enzymes of course are going to
help break this down and notice how a
couple of electrons are now embedded in
the inner mitochondrial membrane and one
of the hydrogen ions has positioned
itself at one of those protein tubes
well this happens repeatedly another
NADH is broken down couple more
electrons embed in the inner
mitochondrial membrane another hydrogen
is positioned itself at one of the
protein tubes and here's an fadh2 that's
broken down and what we're seeing is the
beginning of the electron transport
chain those electrons are going to start
a chain reaction which we've called the
electron transport chain well what
happens with with these electrons this
is why it's called the electron
transport chain these electrons are
going to start a chain reaction of
events where those hydrogen's are going
to be transported out of the matrix and
so the electrons as they transfer from
protein channel to protein channel by
protein channel as they transfer from
the protein channels they provide the
energy to pull these hydrogens out of
the matrix and this will set up the next
step of the electron transport chain
so once all the hydrogens have been
pulled out of the matriot out of the
matrix they have accumulated in a very
large amount now and this is going to
lead to really rapid diffusion through
the molecule labeled ATP synthase and so
those hydrogen ions are going to
activate this enzyme this molecule
called ATP synthase and notice how ATP
synthase has an adp and a P attached to
it they just need the ATP synthase just
needs something to bond the phosphate
with the ADP and that's the job of the
hydrogen ion so what the hydrogen does
is it loads itself into ATP synthase
simple diffusion from a high
concentration to a low and as the
hydrogen diffuses through the mechanical
forces bring together the adp and the P
to create ATP and this happens
repeatedly over and over and over so
here's another adp and another phosphate
here's another hydrogen and as the
hydrogen diffuses through ATP is created
and this happens repeatedly over and
over and over up to 34 times well as we
wind down notice how there are some
hydrogens and electrons that are now
regather incide the matrix there has to
be a way to clean these up in order to
keep the process moving and this is
where the water is formed if you look at
the chemical formula of cellular
respiration one of the one of the
products that's formed as water
well oxygen from the air that we breathe
well bond with two of the hydrogen's and
two of the electrons to form a molecule
of water this is where we get the water
in the chemical reaction of of cellular
respiration it comes from the end of the
electron transport chain
so if you're in my class we'll talk
about this essay in more detail well as
I wrap this up I want to thank you for
watching and you know pause the video
here try to have try to answer these
questions for review practice and you
know leave your comments in the box
below thanks for watching